[Music]
my name is Brendan Lowry and I'm the
creator and founder of people don't feel
what's exciting about capturing people
with photography is that there are
always new stories to tell I don't think
people realize how much is happening in
Philadelphia and how many hidden gems
there actually are there's been a lot
that's changed over the past ten years
in this city it's really exciting to be
here whether that's in the arts world in
the restaurant world there's just a lot
of things happening within a bunch of
different industries that make Philly a
really exciting place to be Bach is this
old massive school building which has
now been turned into essentially a
massive makerspace so it's exciting to
see this thing that was going to be
completely empty now full of life and
something that's actually impacting the
community the economy and really a place
where anyone can go and be inspired I'm
really excited for the event I don't
think there's been anything like this in
Philly it's super unique it's rare that
we're able to have all these artists in
the same room at the same time in this
amazing auditorium that was empty a
couple of years ago and now we're using
it to celebrate fill it off the artists
celebrate Philadelphia filmmakers and
really just show why Philly is such a
unique place it's a really great
building and a great culture and
honestly this event represents it really
well when I walked into the building
tonight I saw this amazing blue light
and I said what did chase put on tonight
[Music]
the level of curiosity that I have is
what he really drives me to try and find
these moments and to capture these
moments forcing myself to not always
look at what everyone else is looking at
and to sort of look the other way and
point my camera in that direction is
exciting to me and it leads me down a
bunch of different paths that I never
thought that I would maybe take
you